big news from the world of making a
murderer Brendan Dassey was convicted in
2007 in the murder of photographer
Teresa Halbach this was a huge Netflix
documentary series called making a
murderer Brendan Dassey zung chol Steven
Avery also convicted of that murder I
have been saying for months since I
first commented on this that Brendan
Dassey whatever his involvement was or
was not in that murder he was not of the
mental capacity to even understand what
was going on he gave a completely
coached confession to investigators who
questioned him without his mother
present and the big news is that the
conviction of Brendan Dassey has been
overturned by a federal judge in
Milwaukee according to court documents
that have been obtained by a number of
news outlets there are now 90 days
during which this decision can be
appealed and otherwise Brendan will go
free I believe this is the right
decision Louis I happen to have real
questions about whether Brendan Dassey
was involved at all I'm not sure if
Steven Avery was actually involved but
as far as Brendan Dassey xin volved
meant doesn't matter this is a kid of
low IQ demonstrably low confirmed by the
court and the judge's ruling says that
who had no clue what on earth was going
on and if you watch the documentary you
would see investigators saying Brendan
tell us what you did to Teresa he says
oh we we stabbed her and that wasn't the
right answer to investigator so they go
Brendan tell us what you really did stop
lying now tell us the truth about what
you did we shot her that's right Brendan
that's what you did a total fishing
expedition a total violation of what
should have been this kids actual rights
with regard to this prosecution and I
believe that this is the right decision
uh yeah it's what that was maybe one of
the hardest things I ever had to watch
yeah Wiz uh and the the whole series is
great if it wasn't for the series this
would not have happened and we are gonna
continue following it as far as Steven
Avery as well which is a whole other
story yeah well I hear that there's
going to be a new season it's so this of
course has been continuing and I believe
that he is innocent as well I could be
wrong just my opinion
so I cheers to the the documentary to
the filmmakers and i'm i'm i'm happy for
Brandon if you believe that Brendan
Dassey uh that there were no problems at
all with the prosecution of Brendan
Dassey and that he should be sitting in
prison a send me an email because I
truly don't get it